this is a story about a horse and if you
don't know I love horses I love
everything about horses I love horse
movie Secretariat Seabiscuit champ with
john-boy back in the days I probably
watch John Boyd
50 times in Iran until I finally met
John with just a very emotional movie to
me
I love horse paintings I love growing a
racetrack I love going to the Derby I
love going to Kentucky Derby I love
horses but this is a story about an
owner and a horse he didn't believe in
it's a story of an owner names I yet and
this is a man very wealthy man he's been
in a horse business for very very long
time and every year horse owners go to
this auction and they bet on horses and
they buy horses now is that yet who I
believe is an Egyptian millionaire he
not only by sources he also sells his
own horses
so in this auction he sold one of his
horses he just didn't believe the source
was gonna do it so he gave it up to
auction so everybody these millionaires
they bring different analysts these are
people that calculate which horse is
gonna do good based on certain data that
they pull up right and so this guy
brings a guy named Jeff now Jeff for you
to know he's very decked out very
educated brilliant guy he's a guy that
was in Wall Street did very well in his
mid late 20s and then he got bored he
says like I love horses I'm just gonna
get into the horse business and he came
out with a formula on how to pick
winning horses and it's very different
than some of the other people are they
picked their horses just okay go at it
let me know which horse I should bet on
Sisk right so Jeff goes and starts doing
this investigation and by the way these
horses don't have names they're
typically year old and they have numbers
like it's not gonna be certain names
gonna do number 86 number 129 that's
what you're buying you're buying the
number right and so Jeff goes and does
his due diligence and it comes back and
say it says okay so who should I buy he
says uh there's not a single horse for
you to buy today he says what do you
mean and that one horse there's not a
single horse that's worth the investing
money he says how about that one horse
what a great pedigree waste of time
don't do it so what do I do
he says look I think the best horse for
you to bet on this year for the Derby
Derby is the horse you put up for
auction he says wait a minute the horse
that I'm selling that I sold yes do you
want me to buy back my own horse that's
like comical yes you got to go back and
buy that horse
it's kind of weird why do you say that
let me explain to you why
should they pull up the data and here's
the data he's dead horse just so you
know when it came to height he was in
the 56 percentile of height you know
what that means you know how parents go
to the doctor and doctor says your four
year old son is in the 89th percentile
what does that mean out of 100 kids he's
gonna be taller than 89 of them this
horse was in the 56 percentile when it
came down to the weight he was in the 61
percentile light horse short horse when
he came down to pedigree ready 70% off
nothing impressive but Jeff Telles I yet
when it comes down to his hearts left
ventricle ready ninety nine point six
one percentile let me see this again
ninety nine point six one percentile
that means out of a thousand horses only
three of them have a bigger left
ventricle you got a bet on this horse
cuz he's got a big heart and he's gonna
fight and when you race you need a horse
with a big heart do you understand my
gosh I hope you're right or make sense
cuz a lot of open all all these you know
predictive analytics they like to look
at guys would be horses with big nostril
scissors no no no it's all about the
left ventricle so it gets this horse you
know what he ends up naming this horse
doing that he bought back the one that
he didn't believe in ready American
Pharoah you know what American throw
does in 2015 American flora does in 2015
something that no horse had done for 39
years American Pharoah goes and wins the
Triple Crown second fastest time ever
not only that American Pharoah wins the
Breeders Cup that same year never been
done before not only does he win the
Breeders Cup he wins by six and a half
lengths now what does this have to do
with anything this was a special horse
butt pad I mean that's great that he won
all that stuff what's your point in 2006
two billionaires fought for one horse
because that horse had such great height
weight pedigree everybody wanted to
source great pedigree you know what they
paid for that horse sixteen million
dollars you can go to your own research
2006 most expensive horse ever buy
an option you'll see 16 million dollars
do you know what that horses courier
earnings was ever-ready $10,000 16
million dollars $10,000 what does this
have to do with you
everything see back in 2009 I was in a
meeting and I'll never forget this the
Chairman the company got up and he said
every 10 years I picked somebody that I
believe is gonna be the future of the
industry and I Bank on him for a decade
and everyone sitting in the room it
wasn't a lot of people that were waiting
to see what name was gonna be mentioned
the names were brought up wasn't my name
i sat in that room and I said wow you
picked the guy that played professional
sports for college
you picked the guy that is American I'm
Middle Eastern I don't have a degree I
never played organized sports
you picked the guy that looked the part
you picked the guy that everything made
sense good pedigree everything was
proper but he never saw the heart you
never saw the character I said no
problem do you know how many times I
replayed that talk in my own mind so
many times you know why see why you're
watching this some of you may be saying
I wish I was taller I wish had better
skin I wish I were nicer eyes I wish my
nose was smaller I wish I was a little
bit stronger I wish I was a better
communicator I wish had a better degree
I wish my parents were Kennedy sort of
Rockefeller sort of Vanderbilt I don't
know I just wish my parents had a name I
mean I wish I had those contacts I wish
my parents did something with their
lives see those things don't matter what
matters is what nobody sees and it's
right here it's your left ventricle it's
your heart
people can't see this everybody sees
degrees everybody sees height everybody
sees last name nobody sees the heart I'm
in my garage right now it's 12:30 Sunday
night kids are sleeping upstairs you can
see the light just went off you know why
because I don't want to make a lot of
noise these kids are asleep I got to go
to school early in the morning you know
what I think about all the time as I'm
chasing and I'm going after my vision of
what I want to do
I think about that heart no one knows
your heart so as you're watching this
and you're a little bit down on yourself
maybe not everything's going right do
not let the world judge you on the
outside go show the world what's on the
inside and by the way if you get the
chills and if you got tears in your eyes
right now pay your bet text us to five
other people because I bet there's other
people that also need to hear this
message and if I lost send me a tweet
I'll answer any question may have but
either way have a killer week this week
love you